the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we will discuss the inverse
hyperbolic functions and with this
lecture finish our block on the
logarithmic exponential and hyperbolic
functions and what we're going to find
is that much of what we have to say
today is simply a specific application
to a special function of the same theory
that we were talking about in general
before recall that we can always talk
about an inverse function if the
original function is a one-to-one
function for example to introduce
today's topic suppose we take the
function y equals hyperbolic sine x y
equals sin checks well as we saw last
time the graph y equal of y equals and x
is this and we can see the glance that
this clearly is a one-to-one function in
fact the derivative of sinh is cosh and
as we've seen also last time the cosh
can never be negative
in fact the cosh can't be less than 1 so
here is a curve that's always rising and
in fact in general rising quite steeply
in any event we can therefore talk about
the inverse hyperbolic sine alright and
how do we get the inverse function in
general well we've always seen that to
invert a function all we have to do is
to reflect the original graph with
respect to the line y equals x or again
in more slow motion we rotate through 90
degrees and then flip the graph over and
in any event whichever way you want to
look at this thing we obtain that the
graph y equals inverse hyperbolic sine X
is this particular curve over here this
is the graph of the inverse hyperbolic
sine now again what was the main issue
or the main property of inverse
functions the idea was that once we knew
the original function we could by a
change in emphasis study the inverse
function well by way of illustration
let's suppose we take the functional
relationship y equals inverse hyperbolic
sine X
and we say let's find dy/dx recall that
what we know how to do is how to
differentiate the hyperbolic sine
consequently given that y equals the
inverse hyperbolic sine X we simply
switch the emphasis and say look at this
is the same as saying that x equals
since Y and if X equal since Y we
already know that the derivative of X
with respect to Y is cosh Y and since
the derivative of Y with respect to X is
the reciprocal of the derivative of X
with respect to Y we can conclude from
this that the y DX is 1 over cosh Y and
in a certain manner of speaking we're
all finished now we have found that the
derivative of inverse sinh X is 1 over
cosh Y the only problem is is that as
we've said many times also before that
if Y is given as a function of X we
would like the Y DX expressed in terms
of X or to put it in still different
words usually when you're given an
expression like dy/dx you're asked to
evaluate this when X is some particular
value not when y is some particular
value at any rate we do much the same
here as we did with the inverse circular
trig functions namely having arrived
that one over cosh Y and remembering
that the relationship that ties in x and
y is that x equals sinh Y we invoke the
fundamental identity that cosh squared y
minus sinh squared Y is one from which
we can conclude that cosh Y and here we
have to be a little bit careful if we
solve this algebraically we find that
cosh Y is plus or minus the square root
of 1 plus sinh squared Y but recalling
that cosh can never be negative it means
that for this particular problem the
minus sign does not apply in other words
since cosh has to be at least as big at
1 you see that cosh Y is plus the square
root of 1 plus sinh squared Y now keep
in mind why we went to this identity in
the first
place the reason we went to this
identity in the first place is if we
come back to the beginning of our
problem we see that we had that X is
equal to since Y in other words down
here now all we do is we place inch
white by a synonym namely X and we
arrive at the fact that cosh Y is the
square root of 1 plus x squared
therefore since the Y DX is the
reciprocal of cos Y the derivative of Y
with respect to X is 1 over the square
root of 1 plus x squared and this is
summarized in our last step over here in
other words the derivative of the
inverse hyperbolic sine of X with
respect to X is 1 over the square root
of 1 plus x squared now you see the
first thing I want to point out here is
to observe that without worrying about
what's important about this result is to
observe again that we obtain this
information virtually free of charge by
knowing the calculus of the regular
hyperbolic functions you see this result
was obtained without any new knowledge
the other thing I'd like to point out
here is somewhat more subtle and we also
mentioned this in the same context but
from a different point of view when we
dealt with the inverse circular
functions many people will say things
like who needs the inverse hyperbolic
functions how many times am I going to
be confronted with having to work with
inverse hyperbolic functions and the
interesting point
that's typifies by this result is that
if we now invert this emphasis in other
words if we now read this equation from
right to left observe that if you start
with the function 1 over the square root
of 1 plus x squared which is hardly a
hyperbolic function this is a fairly
straightforward algebraic function
notice that the inverse derivative leads
to an inverse hyperbolic sign in other
words stated from a different
perspective and using our language of
the indefinite integral notice that what
we have here is that the indefinite
integral DX over the square root of 1
plus x squared is inverse hyperbolic
sine X plus a constant
now what does this mean say
geometrically suppose we take the curve
y equals 1 over the square root of 1
plus x squared without beating this
thing to death it should be fairly
straightforward at this stage of the
game that the graph of this function can
be obtained and it looks something like
this
in fact intuitively notice that Y will
be maximum when my denominator is
smallest my denominator is smallest when
x is 0 so the maximum value of y occurs
when x is 0 at which case Y is 1 also if
I replace X by minus X I don't change
the function and therefore the graph
it's an even function the graph is
symmetric with respect to the y axis etc
at any rate I have a picture like this
and now suppose I want to find the area
of the region R where R is bounded above
by this curve below by the x-axis on the
left by the y-axis and on the right by
the line x equals T the area of the
region R which is a function of T is
given by what the definite integral from
0 to t DX over the square root of 1 plus
x squared the point is I could as we
talked about in the previous block try
to evaluate this as the limit of a sum
in other words an infinite sum and go
through all sorts of work to try to do
this thing but the first fundamental
theorem tells us in this particular case
that this particular area just turns out
to be the inverse hyperbolic sine of T
in other words notice that a non
trigonometric region has as its answer
an inverse hyperbolic trigonometric
function so if you want this thing more
specifically for example notice that if
you want the area of this region from 0
to 1 from 0 to 1 the answer to this
problem just would have been the inverse
hyperbolic sine of 1 in other words e to
the 1 minus e to the minus 1 over 2 in
other words notice how he sneaks in to a
problem which basically doesn't seem to
have any relationship to e by the way as
a very brief aside for what
worth it's rather interesting to observe
that this last equation that we've
written down gives a rather interesting
definition of the inverse hyperbolic
sine without having to refer to a
hyperbola or anything trigonometric in
other words notice that the inverse
hyperbolic sine can be defined as an
integral which is what we've really done
over here but again that's just an aside
the main point that I want us to get a
hold of over here was the fact that you
solve non hyperbolic functions
conveniently if we have mastered the
hyperbolic functions well any rate
here's another interesting question that
comes up and I thought that we should
mention this also notice that we arrived
at this result by doing the thing in
Reverse you recall that we started with
y equals inverse hyperbolic sine X and
show that the derivative of that
function was 1 over the square root of 1
plus x squared an interesting question
might have been what if we had started
with the integral being given and we
hadn't have differentiated the inverse
hyperbolic sine how could we have got
from here to the inverse hyperbolic sine
and I thought I would mention this
because there may be some confusion
especially if you've taken to heart
certain advice that I gave you earlier
when we dealt with the inverse circular
functions remember I told you that
whenever you see something like the sum
of two squares to think of a right
triangle in other words if you have the
square root of 1 plus x squared it seems
to me that the triangle that suggests
itself is something like this in other
words if I call this side X I call this
side 1 and this is the square root of 1
plus x squared it would seem to me that
I could make a circular trigonometric
substitution over here in fact what
seems to dictate itself over here is to
make the substitution let tan theta
equal X now if I let tan theta equal X
watch what happens here
I get secant squared theta D theta
equals DX taking the differential of
both sides I also get looking at my
reference triangle that the square root
of 1 plus x squared is secant theta see
this this over this is secant theta
at any rate then making this
substitution in here replacing DX by
secant squared theta D theta and the
square root of 1 plus x squared by
secant theta I wind up with integral
secant theta D theta now you see what
I've done here is I have successfully
transformed and integral in terms of X
into 1 in terms of theta
but without belaboring this point it
turns out that is at this stage of the
game we do not know how to exhibit a
function whose derivative with respect
to theta is secant theta in other words
we've made the substitution but we wind
up with an integral that's just as tough
to handle as the one that we started
with you see in this case trying to make
a circular trigonometric substitution
wouldn't have helped us very much what
I'd like to show you was again an
interesting connection between the
circular functions and the hyperbolic
functions namely when we did this
particular thing over here using our
reference triangle what was the
reference triangle really taking the
place off notice that if we let X equal
tan theta
certainly 1 plus x squared is 1 plus tan
squared theta but there is a
trigonometric identity that says 1 plus
tan squared theta is secant squared
theta
I think the usual way that's given is
that secant squared theta minus tan
squared theta is 1 this is the result
that we used we didn't really use the
triangle other than to get this result
more visually the point is is there a
hyperbolic function that has the same
format is there a hyperbolic identity
which says that the difference of two
squares is 1 the answer is well remember
our basic hyperbolic identity is that
cosh squared theta minus sin squared
theta is 1 in other words structurally
notice that since theta does for the
hyperbolic functions what tan theta does
for the circular functions see that the
common structure here we're going to
reinforce this in the next block by
doing problems like this again but for
the time being I thought I would like to
point this thing out to you in other
words what the approach is is that when
you try a circular function substitution
and it doesn't give you the answer that
you want
meaning that you wind up with an
integral that's just as tough to handle
as the original one you look for the
corresponding hyperbolic function in
other words what hyperbolic function
plays to the hyperbolic identity the
same role that this trigonometric
function played to the circular identity
and it was in this case we replace tan
theta by sin CH theta in other words
instead of making the substitution x
equals tangent theta we make the
substitution x equals Cinch theta and
now watch what happens as we work this
thing quite mechanically the
differential of Cinch theta is cos theta
d-theta and the square root of 1 plus x
squared is the square root of 1 plus sin
squared theta but notice that because of
the relationship between Cinch and cosh
that's how we rigged this thing that's
why we chose X to be sin theta
notice that the square root of 1 plus
sin squared theta is just cosh theta and
therefore when we now substitute for DX
over the square root of 1 plus x squared
we get what for DX we have cosh theta
d-theta for the square root of 1 plus x
squared we have cosh theta cos theta D
theta over cosh theta is just D theta
and now we see the answer is quite
simply theta plus C but what was data
since since theta was X theta was
inverse hyperbolic sine X and you see
this is the technique whereby starting
with the integral DX over the square
root of 1 plus x squared we can show
that we must have started with inverse
inch at any rate this will be reinforced
in homework problems it will be
reinforced in the next block when we
talk about techniques of integration but
I just wanted to again show the
similarity the things in common between
the hyperbolic functions and the
circular functions and how they're
intertwine let's make a few more
comments while
rather you know we mentioned that the
hyperbolic functions were really
combinations of exponential functions
remember cosh X was e to the X plus e to
the minus x over 2 etc so somehow or
other if the hyperbolic functions can be
expressed in terms of Exponential's it
would seem that the inverse hyperbolic
functions should be expressible in terms
of the inverse of Exponential's namely
in terms of logarithms and so I thought
that I would try to go through some of
these final points with you and for
example ask the following question given
that y equals inverse sinh X is there a
way of writing this in terms of
something that uses our natural
logarithms see another reason being one
that if we've already learned natural
logs and Exponential's it would seem
that whenever we can reduce unfamiliar
names to more familiar ones
psychologically we feel much more at
home in dealing with the concepts in
other words one might feel strange
working with inverse hyperbolic sign
because he hasn't seen that very much
but if he's used to seeing logarithms
that wouldn't seem quite as strange at
any rate let's see how one could proceed
here in other words starting out with y
equals inverse sinh Jack's notice that
by the property the basic definition of
inverse functions I can now write that x
equals sinh Y now for obvious reasons
since I want to get the inverse of
Exponential's in here it would seem to
me that I should express since Y in
terms of Exponential's and going again
back to basic definitions since Y is e
to the Y minus e to the minus y over 2
in other words in terms of Exponential's
X is equal to e to the Y minus e to the
minus y over 2 if I now cross multiply I
get that 2x is equal to e to the Y minus
now notice that e to the minus y is just
1 over e to the Y so I wind up now with
this particular equation and multiplying
through by e to the Y to clear fractions
in my denominator
clear my denominators I wind up with
what e to the 2y minus 2x e to the Y
minus one equals zero and if I now
recall that e to the 2 y is the square
of either Y observe that what I now have
is a quadratic equation in eetu the Y I
have a quadratic equation in each of the
Y now since I have a quadratic equation
in e to the Y I can use the quadratic
formula to solve for e to the Y if I do
this I get what remember how this thing
works I take the coefficient of this
term minus that that's 2x plus or minus
the square root of this squared minus 4
times this times the coefficient of e to
the Y squared in other words leaving the
details as being fairly obvious e to the
Y is 2x plus or minus the square root of
4x squared plus 4 all over 2 and
noticing now that the 4 can be factored
out here is a 2 and I can cancel a 2
then from both the numerator and the
denominator I wind up with e to the Y is
X plus or minus the square root of x
squared plus 1 the point to keep in mind
now is remember that in terms of
Exponential's e to the Y can never be
negative
observe that the square root of x
squared plus 1 is bigger than X in
magnitude you see CX would be just a
positive square root of x squared so the
positive square root of x squared plus 1
is bigger than X in magnitude
consequently if I use the minus sign
here I'd be taking away more than when I
had that would make my answer negative
which would be a contradiction since
either the Y can't be negative
in other words again for in terms of
this particular problem the minus root
the minus sign here is extraneous and we
therefore wind up with what e to the Y
is X plus the square root of x squared
plus 1 therefore Y itself in
the log of X plus the square root of X
square plus 1 to the base e which we've
already seen is called the natural log
in other words going back now say from
the first step to the last I guess we
can now fill in what's really happened
here in other words a synonym for
inverse since X is the natural log of X
plus the square root of x squared plus 1
so notice that we can study the inverse
since for example in terms of a suitably
chosen natural log and of course there
are many more examples that we could use
along these lines but again I think that
with the previous explanation coupled
with the fact that there will be ample
exercises and the like I think the
message has become clear as far as the
inverse hyperbolic sign is concerned
what I would like to do now is to turn
to another facet of inverse functions
something that involves principal values
the same as it did with the circular
functions we wind up with the same
problem as before when we come to the
idea that technically speaking you
cannot talk about an inverse function
unless the original function is
one-to-one and so therefore when one
talks about the inverse hyperbolic
cosine one is in a way looking for
trouble if one doesn't keep his eye on
exactly what's going on around here
namely if we look at the graph y equals
hyperbolic cosine x observe that whereas
the function is single valued it is not
one-to-one
in fact there is a zero derivative at
this point here which leads us to
believe that maybe what we should have
done was to have broken this curve down
into the union of two one-to-one
functions let me call this curve y
equals c1 of X and let me call this
branch here y equals c2 of X notice that
both c1 of x + c2 of X are one-to-one
functions in fact let's write this more
formally using the picture as a guide
let's do the following analytically
let's say this
fine C sub 1 of X to be Cossacks
provided that X is at least as big as 0
again I mentioned this with the circular
functions let me reinforce this again to
define a function it's not enough to
tell the rule you must also tell the
domain notice that c1 is not the same as
cosh because the domain of cosh is all
real numbers the domain of c1 is just
the non-negative reals at any rate I
defined c1 to be cosh X where X is at
least as big as 0 i define c2 of X to be
cosh X where X is no bigger than 0 in
other words these two functions are
different because even though the
functional relations are the same the
domains are different the interesting
point is what that Cossacks is the union
of c1 and c2 but the important point is
that both c1 and c2 are one-to-one and
because they're one-to-one they're
inverses exist in other words I can talk
meaningfully about c1 inverse and c2
inverse in fact pictorially what I have
is this see if I take the curve y equals
cosh X and reflected about the 45-degree
line this is the curve that I get you
see it's a double value curve all I'm
saying is look at if we look at y equals
c1 X which is a one-to-one function its
inverse is c1 inverse X which is this
piece over here and if on the other hand
we look at y equals c2 X that's this
branch over here it's inverse as this
you see notice that these two pieces are
symmetric with respect to the line y
equals x and these two pieces are
symmetric with respect to the line y
equals x as long as we break this down
into the union of two pieces we can talk
about inverse functions now you see the
interesting point is that what most
authors traditionally refer to as the
inverse hyperbolic cosine of X is really
what we call c1 inverse of X in other
words the definition y equals inverse
hyperbolic cosine X is x equals cosh Y
and this is very important and Y is at
least as big as 0 in other words notice
that the domain of cosh inverse X is
really X has to be at least as big as 1
but that's not the important point here
what I do want you to see over here is
that when you put this restriction on is
that if you left this restriction out
there would be no inverse function here
I'll come back to that in a moment
let me just reinforce what we've talked
about before and let's find the
derivative of inverse cosh X in other
words let's find dy/dx if y equals
inverse cosh X well again what is the
definition y equals inverse cosh X it
means x equals cosh Y where Y is
positive okay
if X equals cosh Y DX dy is since Y and
we'll keep track of the fact that Y is
positive actually Y is not negative
therefore the reciprocal of DX dy will
be dy/dx
in other words dy/dx is 1 over since Y
and this would be a correct answer
except as usual
we would like to be able to express
dy/dx for a given value of X what we do
now is remembering that X's cosh Y we
invoke the identity again cosh squared Y
minus sinh squared Y is 1 from which we
can solve and find that since Y is plus
or minus the square root of x squared
minus 1 and by the way I'm not going to
remove the extraneous sign here because
in a certain manner of speaking it is
only extraneous because we are imposing
the condition that Y is positive C in
other words once we assume that Y is
positive remember that since Y is
positive for positive values of y and
negative for negative values of y
consequently the assumption that Y is
positive forces us to accept the fact
that
since Y is positive and that's what
forces us in terms of the restriction
that we impose the fact that Y has to be
at least as big as 0 Y we can get rid of
the minus sign here and so we wind up
with what since Y is the square positive
square root of cosh squared Y minus 1
but cosh Y as X in this problem and now
in other words since Y and this problem
is the positive square root of x squared
minus 1 by the way don't be nervous here
you might say couldn't this be imaginary
in other words what happens if x squared
is less than 1 remember X is at least as
big as 1 so this thing here kept in the
square root sign can never be negative
but at any rate what we now wind up with
is that the derivative of inverse cosh X
with respect to X is 1 over the square
root of x squared minus 1 now again
there's no law that says that a person
couldn't have been on the negative
branch of this curve in other words if
all you mean by inverse cosh is the
inverse of cosh with no restriction to
branch what we've really proven is this
and let me summarize on this particular
point what we've really proven is this
that the derivative of C 1 inverse is 1
over the square root of x squared minus
1 the derivative of C 2 inverse is 1
over minus the square root of x squared
minus 1 I've taken the liberty of
putting the minus down with the square
root sign rather than with the fraction
itself to emphasize the fact that which
of the two signs we choose depends on
whether we're looking at the branch for
which Y is above the x-axis or the
branch for which Y is below the x-axis
in other words what we don't want to
happen here is for people to lose track
of the fact that all we have done is
made a convention so we can talk about
one-to-one functions and inverse
functions more meaningfully but you can
be on either of these particular
branches in any event this does complete
our discussion of the hyperbolic
functions and we will now turn our
attention to utilizing these results we
will
techniques of integration and the like
but at any rate until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate